- Hallo, Selma.
Was liest du?
- Das Architekturbüro hat ein neues
Wohnungsbauprojekt.
Auf dem Gebiet eines ehemaligen Tagebaus
im Ruhrgebiet
werden ökologische Wohnungen für
verschiedene Generationen gebaut.
Ich informiere mich darüber.
- Tagebau?
- Während des industriellen Zeitalters
um 1800
entdeckte man im Ruhrgebiet große
Kohlevorkommen.
Seitdem wurde im Ruhrgebiet unter
schweren Arbeitsbedingungen
viel Bergbau betrieben.
Die Region hatte während des Aufschwungs
fast 6 Millionen Einwohner.
Heute ist die Nachfrage an Braun- und
Steinkohle gesunken
und deshalb werden viele Bergwerke
geschlossen.
Und die Frage ist: Was macht man mit
ihnen?
Schrebergärten kann man nicht überall
bauen.
Zufrieden?
- Selma, achte auf deinen Ton!
Du musst mich und deinen Vater verstehen.
- Und wer versteht mich?
Hey, Lisa. Ich brauche deine Hilfe!
Liebe Grüße, Selma.